how are you did you have a good weekend
yeah i did everything's good mm-hmm
life is fine very good because i've been
hard at work you know
oh that's right i don't care at all
this is true you know a lot of people i
i'm constantly thinking of ways to uh
make the show more exciting and dynamic
in whatever way i can before we give up
completely and get into the auto
business
and uh anyway what i thought i'd do is
the big thing today is psychics
sidekicks are the big thing you know
there's the psychic hotline psychic
friends
everyone's talking about psychic
psychics are make up half the guess on
the daytime talk shows it's true
and so i thought let's do something with
psychics on this show
so ladies and gentlemen i went out into
new york city
and i actually talked to all the most
prominent psychics that we could find in
the yellow pages
to try and find out anything we could
just about
are these people legit yeah how's the
show gonna be doing in the future
what's gonna happen and uh we found out
some pretty
impressive stuff so ladies and gentlemen
enjoy my visit with the psychics of new
york city
okay i'm sitting here right now with
astounding vilma is that correct
velma v-e-l-m-a v-e velma
you got it and it's astounding i'm very
astounding
i always have you and you are a palmist
is that right i'm a promise i do magic i
do palmistry and i do
a mind-reading act which we call
transmission of thoughts
so this is the human hand right here
these lines actually
this one happens to be the line of heart
the line of emotion this is the heart
line right here
this is the line of head intelligence
this is the line of success this is the
line of light but there are many
other aspects this is the line of you
got it tic-tac-toe now i'll go first
then you here we go wait a minute what
about here
oh interesting and then i'll go here and
i'll go
no no a light-eared female will come
into your life that you'll care about
hmm that would be um thurman wouldn't it
i don't know who that is
i'll take what you said as meaningless
therma do you know she's born in a
summer month later
no she won't return my calls okay what's
let's get it tell me your birthday
uh april 18th 4 18
63. your minor number is a one
which means you're a leader not a
follower yes i'm a leader that's right
you are but your major number is a five
and five is the number of communications
let me ask you what year you were born
in
1930. you were born in 1930 let me show
you something right here
okay 19 30.
all right now you said eight is the
number of power money okay eight goes
into 19 how many times
it goes in two right two you said was
the
number for growth action action
right yeah how many ones are there in
two
that's two but there are two what's in
two two ones
that gives us a one and then one would
be a number
right a loneliest number
i noticed something about your hand
which is very interesting yeah that's
by putting vaseline on it it's clearing
up oh this is this
this is the mount of venus what does
that mean right there love
sympathy passion virility and sensuality
yeah i like the
i like to call it love that's what it is
[Music]
should we go on that yeah you like that
and oh notice notice it's getting higher
and higher
it's getting bigger and bigger how crap
oh velma how does this work do i you
never
you drink the tea then how do you read
the tea leaves
because the tea leaves would stay at the
bottom i'll show you oh so i got to
drink the whole cup of tea first before
we can even get started
yeah well would you like some candies
with it
but you must enjoy it and also
concentrate i don't enjoy anything
i was raised irish catholic i'm very
uptight what i say within the next three
years
mostly is a lot of parties and
happy occasions that people are doing
parties i'm at parties
is james kahn there i don't see james
conder
okay now your name is
[Music]
that's interesting they're holy magical
cards but you shuffle them just like
it's a
cheap game of poker you will be living
uh oh skull
look at that
look at that what does that mean that's
that's a that's you i don't know much
about tarot cards but you can't tell me
one with a big
skull on it is it good that's got to be
a bad card
no it's a very good card especially with
a medical student
you and your confounded jokes so did you
say i was going to be in a car accident
no i said be careful not to be
well thank you gee great that's worth it
okay
that's worth whatever you're asking what
is all this stuff right here
my home is my palace in reality does
major healy know that you have this i
think you'd be kind of upset janey
um this is my aladdin's lab and
in one of my magic acts when i rubbed
the lamp it did
the aladdin came out look at this it's
got a toggle switch it's kind of oh
now you're getting it this is the uh
early 60s version of it look at that
right there and we noticed when i came
in here there's a secret compartment
right here that's the secret what is
this lead right now
it opens where does it go
[Music]
the biggest thing in my life is my tv
show
it means everything to me and for a tv
show to be successful you have to get
good guests
and i want you to look into the ball
right now and i want you to tell me
what's the biggest guest that i can
expect to come on my show
in the next month
conan i'll be appearing
we'll have fun fun fun
all right well that was a lot of fun but
uh i think we find out once and for all
that
those fortune tellers are way off base
didn't we andy
yes definitely
[Laughter]
thanks